so as of last night 200 inmates from our
jail system had been released that
action last night allowed us to hit a
major major milestone and none of us
expected this crisis but one thing that
has come out of it has that our jail
population continues to decline
so that's New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio touting the release of hundreds
of prisoners as part of an effort to
combat the spread of the virus this is a
trend that's happening in cities and
counties all over the country in New
Jersey
hundreds of low-impact quote low-impact
nonviolent offenders have been released
in order to prevent the spread of this
disease Sean golden is the sheriff of
Monmouth County and he joins me now
sheriff thank you very much for joining
us tonight
Phil Murphy the governor of New Jersey
called this a groundbreaking program do
you consider this a groundbreaking
program well listen if if you consider a
groundbreaking will move away from
inmates that have records of assaulting
officers and resisting arrest and some
sex offenses failure to register for sex
offenders cycle offenses then I guess
you could call groundbreaking listen we
across the state of New Jersey received
a letter from the ACLU on the 20th
certainly went to in order to show cause
immediately in the courts it was
fast-tracked over the weekend by the
23rd we had to have a list of offenders
the quote/unquote low impact nonviolent
offenders to be released out into the
communities and when you looked at that
list that here in Monmouth County was 64
hundreds in the state of New Jersey as
you know almost 900 and you looked at
that list and it had some of those
offenses on it and that's why you know I
thought it was absurd to release inmates
that are still fulfilling a sentence of
where law enforcement were injured in
particular cases one was in salt on a
canine dog the other was throwing fluids
out of law enforcement officer for
resisting arrest
again others failure to register as sex
offenders
and I'm sure when we release them in a
sarcastic way they went out and
registered Martha so you know this this
is an exploitation of a policy that
certainly you know was pushed with an
agenda and rapidly through the Supreme
Court here in New Jersey all right so
right now do these facilities have Cova
19 outbreak problem well here's the
here's the thing our facility does not
we have no positive test cases we do
have two that are in quante nand
isolation in a different pod we went
into what we call the policy and
procedures for communicable diseases
weeks ago not a lot like other dáil
other jails did around the state of New
Jersey not allowing visitation and going
to video visitation and free phone calls
for the inmates having special
visitation for their attorneys checking
them outside with temperatures and
questions and assessment before we bring
them inside and then when we do bring
them inside in the book and they end up
in a separate pod in quarantine for 14
weeks the thing here is none of the
other local jails the wardens
Association is their Sheriff's
Association
none were consulted before this even
went to the show cause order
luckily the prosecutors had a at a
contest piece where they can contest
some of these inmates being released out
into our communities I mean I think
that's amazing and you know when you
think about the fact that there's gonna
be a lot of pressure on communities with
a lot of issues that are going on with
this virus and also with the economy it
seems like a difficult time and it
sounds like your facility you had a
pretty good system in place we had we
have most of them do and in one case we
had a release on Tuesday he was arrested
for shoplifting and theft on Wednesday
so this is what this is what's happening
here
it's certainly a drain on a part of
Public Safety resource worried about
this during this crisis and it's
definitely nice boy patience so thank
you to all our person thank you yeah
good to have you with us and thank you
to all of all of our folks on the front
lines there in New Jersey and elsewhere
and you're doing a great job thank you
sir
thank you